willkommen bei philo cast ich kann
professor felix stalder von der
universität zürich für die hochschule
für künste vorstellen
wir sind gerade auf der tagung über
digitalität befinden uns natürlich in
der natur einfach weil philosophie in
der natur schöner ist für das interview
und veranstalter ich hätte zwei fragen
an sie die erste wäre für die zuschauer
um ins thema rein zu kommen was ist denn
der unterschied zwischen digitalisierung
und digitalität ihrer meinung nach
digitalisierung ist der prozess der
überführung eines analogen sachverhalts
in einen digitalen dass dinge die vorher
mit analogen medien organisiert wurden
nachher mit digitalen medien organisiert
ein beispiel oder eine einer etwas
analoges wäre die alphabetisierung wo
man sozusagen früheren medien schritt
menschen eine neue kulturtechnik
beibringt die da mit ihnen machen können
die sie vorher nicht machen konnten oder
die sie vorher anders gemacht haben
digitalisierung ist ein ähnlicher
prozess wo die grundlagen gelegt werden
um neue handlungsabläufe war auch neue
wahrnehmung formen und neue schon
denkstrukturen zu entwickeln
die digitalität hingegen ist das was
entsteht wenn der prozess der
digitalisierung eine gewisse tiefe und
eine gewisse breite erreicht hat und
damit dieser neuer möglichkeitsraum
entsteht der geprägt ist eben durch
digitale medien und das ist wenn man es
historisch schaut kann man sagen dass es
um das jahr 2000 sind die
digitalisierungsprozess so weit vorher
geschritten
dass wir sagen können heute ist in die
dominante raum in dem wir uns bewegen
als dominante bedingung der wir uns
bewegen nicht mehr die der
schriftlichkeit das wäre quasi die
analog zur alphabetisierung sondern eben
der der digitalität um das noch mal
vielleicht zusammen zu fassen könnte man
sagen dass digitalen
sierung der prozess der technische
entwicklungsprozess ist und digitalität
die kultur mit digitalen medien ist
digitalisierung ist sozusagen der aufbau
einer infrastruktur das nicht nur
technisch ist auch sozusagen lernen
diese zu benutzen und digitalität ist
sozusagen das was diese infrastruktur
dann möglich macht alles klar vielen
dank wir machen eine sitzung gemacht im
rahmen des seminars über die vitalität
wo auch ihr buch behandelt wurde und
dort wurden drei begriffe konkret
genannt das war einmal referenziert
einmal gemeinschaftliches und das dritte
war algorithmics ead etr könnten sie
sagen in welchem zusammenhang dass zu
dem thema digitalität steht und was das
zu bedeuten hat auch innerhalb dieser
drei begriffe diese drei begriffe
referenz ali tät gemeinschaftlichkeit
android zieht gegen grundmuster an wie
wir unter digitalen bedingungen
bedeutung generieren wie also kultur
entsteht kultur definiert als geteilte
bedeutung und alle aushandlungsprozess
die dazu führen damit wir zu einer über
oder die gesellschaft als ganzes sondern
übereinkommen findet was ist richtig was
ist falsch was wollen wir was wollen wir
nicht solche wein kommen sind natürlich
immer umstritten sie sind nie in stein
gemeißelt ist ein dauernder prozess des
aushandeln teilweise ist geht der
langsamer teilweise sind es gewisse
dinge die sehr lang stabil sind
aber es ist immer ein prozess der der
bewegung und dieser wird gemacht indem
eine kulturelle ordnung entsteht
diese entsteht eben über diese drei
moment referenz sanität bedeutet dass
jeder heute wegen damit beschäftigt ist
aus einer unglaublichen vielfalt von
verfügbaren referenzen also bereits
gemachten sozusagen kulturellen
äußerungen bildern videos texte und so
weiter die mir auszuwählen und zu sagen
von diesen 100 millionen videos die es
gibt ist mir jetzt gerade dieses einer
wichtig
das ist eine produktive leistung weil
damit wieder aufmerksamkeit fokussiert
und das ist etwas was wir zwischenzeit
jeden tag dauernd ganz oft machen da
sind die sozialen netzwerke sind dafür
da haben dass wir eben ein foto teilen
können und sagen hey schaut euch das an
dass am main main
das teilen bedeutet ja nur dass ich sagt
dass sie so wichtig ich will auch dass
andere das sehen das ist es dann meine
referenz der realität und daraus
entsteht dann ein weltbild dinge die ich
sehe dinge die meine freunde sehen und
damit entsteht einerseits ein horizont
der uns sagt was wichtig und unwichtig
ist nämlich die dinge die wir sehen und
gleichzeitig kunst die tui ihre ich mich
selbst in dem horizont dass ich der bin
der interessante sachen dazu beiträgt
das mache ich aber eben nicht alleine
ja das ist der zweite begriff sondern
das mache ich gemeinsam mit anderen die
validieren meine auswahl die sagen ja
das bild dass du gemacht hast oder dass
du uns weiterleitet kriegten like das
finden wir auch guten damit sehe ich
dass das was ich mache auf eine resonanz
stößt und gleichzeitig erweitern sie
meinen horizont und auch die bestätigen
ist nur und sie erweitern ihnen auch in
dem sie mir auch dinge vorschlagen die
ich noch nicht gesehen habe in dem ich
ihrem twitter feed folge oder oder ihre
sachen auf facebook bekommen und somit
entsteht so etwas wie ein geteilter
horizont ich und meine freunde oder
meine community oder wie sie das immer
nennen wollen wir wissen was richtig und
falsch ist was wichtig und unwichtig ist
und das passiert ja auf irgend also
irgendwas muss ja das tun dass sich
vorschläge auch bekommen
anhand der dinge die ich geliebt habe
oder nicht oder genau
und da sind einerseits die anderen leute
die mir vorschläge machen aber das
reicht nicht sondern darunter sind dass
das dritte element sind maschine
prozesse automatisierter prozesse die
mir vorschläge machen wie beispielsweise
sagen der hat die letzten zehn
katzenbilder gut gefunden zeigen wir ein
elftes katzenwelt das wieder wieder
gefallen das heißt wir haben
bei auswahl und sortiere mechanismen
dass das referenzieren das
gemeinschaftliche bewerten und aber auch
dass das algorithmische vorsortieren die
bestimmen was ich sehe wie ich mich
selber in dem raum konzentrieren kann
und weil es ja nicht nur darum geht
etwas zu sehen sondern auch zugang zu
dingen zu bekommen wie ich handeln kann
was welche tür mir sozusagen auf geht
und welche tür zugeht
vielen dank ja sehr besonders gefallen
dass diese analyse von digitalität nicht
nur angewandt auf soziale medien wie wir
sie heute kennen irgendwie sinn macht
sondern auch auf mögliche andere soziale
formen
ja und das ist auf jeden fall eine sache
die mir sehr zukunftsweisend erscheint
weil es eben die drei begriffe referenz
realität algorithmen zieht und
gemeinschaftliches sind und nicht die
reine aussage dass facebook so und so
funktioniert sondern dass sie da eine
gewisse grundlage berührt haben
danke fürs zuschauen für die zuschauer
für abonnenten und alles dank für die
likes und bis ein nächstes mal